so wireless mechanical keyboards are
somewhat of a rising trend in pc gaming
these days
how does the g915 stand up is it good is
it bad we'll only find out after this
b-roll
[Music]
what's up everybody this is marion from
geek culture and today we'll be
reviewing the logitech g915 lightspeed
wireless rgb mechanical keyboard oh
that's a that's a model
let me try again
so right out of the box the logitech
g915 comes with a usb receiver
a usb extender
and the charging cable
all decked out in a sleek black steel
reinforced body with a brushed metal
effect the g915 is not only beautifully
designed but can also withstand some
punishment thanks to its durable build
but don't be fooled by its compactness
though it weighs at around 1.025
kilograms so it might weigh a bit when
you're carrying it around
so despite being a gaming keyboard
logitech also knows how to strike the
balance between ergonomics and
functionality at the bottom you can find
a pair of raisable feet that goes either
8 degrees or 12 degrees depending on
your preference it spots a couple of
dedicated media keys to the side they're
all rubberized by the way so it's easy
for you to press on it also comes with a
volume roller so you can control your
sound as precise as you want
and there are a couple more dedicated
rubberized keys at the top these two
alternate between your light speed
wireless connection which is paired with
the usb receiver when you connect it to
your pc
a bluetooth button if you don't want to
use the usb receiver a game mode button
which prevents you from accidentally
pressing onto your windows key
as well as a light control button which
allows you to adjust your brightness of
your keys as well as control your light
sync function on g-hub
these five keys over here are logitech's
g keys they allow for greater amount of
customizability because you can install
macros into them however if you're not
big on macros these g keys might not
find much use and because they're so
close to the other keys you might
accidentally press on them if you're not
careful so now that we've covered all
the utility keys on the g915 let's focus
on the true style of the show the gl
clicky keys
so there's three types of switches that
you can use on the g950
the one we have comes with gl clicky
which makes your keys
produce an audible click
there's jl tactile which gives your keys
a slightly softer click
and then this gl linear which totally
removes the clicking sound
so it's all a matter of preference as to
how you want to type on the g1015 here's
how it sounds like
sounds good right
so the other striking feature of the
g915 is its light sync rgb customization
via the g-hub app
using g-hub you can customize every
single key on the g915
using the full color spectrum comprising
of 16.8 million colors
this essentially eliminates any need to
buy additional keycaps as you can simply
use g-hub to customize the keyboard the
way you want it to be so this
essentially eliminates the need to buy
additional keycaps as you can simply use
g-hub to dictate how you want your
keyboard to look
so cherry on top is that the logitech
g915 pairs nicely with any other
logitech jeep product that comes with
lightsync such as the g304 light speed
gaming mouse
and this provides you with an even more
immersive gaming experience
so while the logitech g915 is impressive
in many aspects there's still a couple
of things that prevent it from being a
perfect 10 out of 10. first off it
doesn't come with a wrist pad attachment
as other high performance wireless
keyboards do
despite having a small form factor some
users still prefer a wrist pad for added
comfortability
in which case the g915 would lose out to
its competitors but if it doesn't bother
you that much it's not that big of a
deal so as a wireless keyboard the g915
will eventually run out of juice hence
the need for a micro usb cable
the good thing is that you won't need to
worry too much about charging as the
g915 packs a battery life of over 12
days the g915 comes at a premium price
of 399 singapore dollars so this might
put off some gamers who are looking for
a more affordable option
that said what you're paying for is
quite the investment as the g915 looks
built to last on your desk for quite
some time with its ultra fast response
times customization options as well as
its durable build the g915 is certainly
up there among the best when it comes to
high performance wireless mechanical
keyboards so that wraps up our review of
the logitech g915 lightspeed wireless
mechanical keyboard if you enjoyed our
video review give it a thumbs up don't
forget to comment share and subscribe
and hit that notification bell icon for
more updates on our geeky reviews and
tidbits and for the full review of our
keyboard there's a link of it in the
description below
till then this is geek culture and i'm
marion signing off
[Music]
you